c'est un chantier très technique qui a
démarré ce matin à 9h30
il va s'agir de déposer les 48 pièces
d'un échafaudage de 200 tonnes dont la
moitié se situe à 40 mètres du sol
il s'avère que la flèche de viollet le
duc étaient en restauration avant
l'incendié bien évidemment la structure
de l'échafaudage a été très endommagé
donc il a fallu la consolidé durant de
nombreux mois à l'aide de poutrelles
métalliques et dresser un second
échafaudage autour et ce matin sur les
lieux
au début du chantier nous nous sommes
entretenus avec l'évêque auxiliaire de
paris monseigneur philippe de mars et il
nous parle de ce chantier très technique
c'est un grand jour à cause de ce que
vous voyez juste derrière moi ou en fait
l'échafaudage qu'on va appeler le
l'échafaudage 2 va se servir de base
pour enlever l'échafaudage un qui était
celui qui était sûr autour de la flèche
de notre dame
quand ça quand quand le feu a pris et
donc on va pouvoir aujourd'hui à partir
d'aujourd'hui mais sur un travail qui va
durer quand même deux trois mois ou ou
trois quatre mois
faire un diagnostic de l'état des
pierres de l'état des routes
sous cet échafaudage numéro un celui là
où a pris le feu et donc à partir de ce
travail de deux constats de constat on
va pouvoir déterminer un calendrier pour
la reconstruction d'un improbable les
professionnels a donc des cordistes vont
découper partie par partie
les éléments calcinés qui vont être
déposées par des grues pour la sécurité
pour évidemment prévenir les chutes
trois filets ont été tendues et toutes
ces opérations vont être suivis par
guidage laser pour éviter la
vulnérabilité de la structure de manière
générale le chantier de notre dame a
connu de nombreuses péripéties puisqu'il
a été ralentie l'été dernier à cause de
la contamination au plomb
et puis à cause de l'épidémie il a été
évidemment stopper il faut savoir que
cette nouvelle phase de travaux va
s'échelonner jusqu'à la fin de l'été